photos inédites delphine jubile art est
au volant de sa voiture quelques heures
avant sa disparition
cette image a été captée par la caméra
d'un parking d'albi nous sommes le mardi
15 décembre 2020 il est 10 heures 23
la jeune infirmière est en ville pour
faire quelques courses
on la voit ici à la borne de sortie du
parking
delphine jubile arts s'apprête à rentrer
à cagnac les mines où elle habite c'est
son premier jour de vacances elle doit
retrouver une amie pour boire le café
[Musique]
alors c'est du voyeurisme vous pas
énorme scoop on va pas se mentir tout le
monde l'aurait 106 ici tous les médias
l'aurait sorti si jamais ces images y
compris les d'heure et puis je pense que
voilà c'est une affaire qui passionne
les français donc ça désinformées
aujourd'hui les affaires se déroule
aussi dans les médias il ya des preuves
qui s'accumulent la journée tu regardes
ans dans l'exercie l'épreuve pour
l'instant il y en a assez
des nouveaux éléments de l'enquète pour
dire que voilà elle envoyait un sms à
telle personne c'est très complet le
reportage il est vraiment très bien fait
et aujourd'hui la justice regarde en
temps réel les documentaires les sujets
qui sont faites sur les affaires pour
moi c'est vraiment des reportages utile
et c'est pas du voyeurisme et de
l'informatique comme moi y en a comme on
est en instruction est ce que c'est pas
un peu dommageable pour lankais pour ce
qu'il fait alors des chaînes info
aujourd'hui tout le monde le fait en
fait qu'est-ce que ça saute ça il doit
le faire mais
surtout c'est surtout guillaume je
t'entends mais là ça ne sert à rien j'en
ai juste en train de dire que le matin
les parties faire ses courses avec sa
voiture est alors nous on est dans une
enquête et on essaie de savoir si ces
sons marc son ex mari qui l'a tué ou qui
l'a pas tuée ce pack l'occurrence ça ne
sert non mais j'ai regardé lourds
pendant qu'il ne sert à rien comme ça
mais ne rien à lenquête et après là où
je rejoins un petit peu benjamin dans sa
question c'est est-ce que ça peut pas
troubler l'enquète parce qu'on a quand
même unique cm2 monde de liberté de
série que j'aime il a donc à un moment
donné est ce que ça peut pas jouer aussi
pour lui il a troublé ou la faire
avancer les montres et les cendres
sur cette affaire on n'a pas d'armes du
crime ouais on n'a pas de corps pas
d'aveux et on a vaguement et on a
vaguement un mobile puisque il pas le
jour où
il ya la trompe évidemment ah là là mais
fermer les comptes communs pour qu'il
n'ait plus accès
mais il ya quand même l'enfant et il n'y
a pas très longtemps récemment et qui a
dit avoir vécu une
dispute un peu violente entre son père
et sa mère ils ont retrouvé
vraisemblablement il aurait retrouvé
derrière les canapés des choses à elle
qui aurait un coût net pour éliminer de
catherine bourgeois est cassé ça avance
l'enquète avance mais est-ce que c'est
aux médias d'en parler je ne suis pas
certain mais c'est en ce moment
qu'on a tous pour toutes les affaires on
n'est plus dans les pubs malheureusement
on n'est plus dans sa
mairie est ce qu'on a besoin de parler
de cette image même offert tout un truc
pendant
illustré en fait le reportage est venu
illustrer parce que finalement il n'y a
pas d'image donc du coup ils vont pas
filmer un canapé ils vont pas filmer des
lunettes derrière un poussin extra donc
qu'ils avaient ces images là ils ont
illustré en fait sur portage qui
effectivement apporte quand même des
évidences nouvelles sur justement le
témoignage du petit garçon il ya dit
qu'il y avait une dispute et lui on a
retranscrit aussi la conversation qu'il
a fait avec les gendarmes lorsqu'il a
appelé pour signaler des séparations de
sa femme où il ne parle absolument pas
de cette dispute donc ça le met quand
même en porte à faux donc ya du nouveau
moi j'essaie d'avancer la couette et
1820 télé pas de sens là on a les photos
alors ça c'est grâce à ces défis du
milliard ça c'est le salon se serait
passé se serait passé le drame une fois
y'a pas une tache de sang y'a pas y'a
pas dissuader d'y arriver à ce niveau
rien voir absolument donc lui pour
l'instant lé enquête n'avance pas et je
me souhaite à présent coup alors qu'en
même temps il ne restait pas plus de
deux ans sans avoir été
au bout d'un an il va être obligée de
sortir le l'après-vente il serait c'est
ça c'est ce qui est pire un silent des
festivals peut être ces deux ans et ça
peut être renouvelée deux amants encore
quatre ans au maximum donc c'était
quasiment trois ans qui laisse s déduit
de la peine évidemment dans un an quoi
qu'il a si ya pas eu de progrès la
société ont déjà donné aux recherches il
ya beaucoup de gens qui me disent aussi
est-ce qu'on peut être condamné qui a
pas deux d'armes de crime et pas de
corps oui la réponse est oui il ya eu
plein de cas dans l'histoire de la
justice on était condamné halak avait
pas de corps et les fautes et les
erreurs judiciaires mais je rappelle que
gratuite française le doute est censé
toujours profiter
asma d'innocence mais allez un sens de
doute un messie les options de
culpabilité et peut aussi être inculpé
en recoupant justement et s'il a menti
si on découvre qu'il a menti justement
est le témoignage a été un peu tronqué
il pourrait être inquiété aussi